when we when we go out of the
um the box obviously we we we do a right
into the city room
at 10 31 make our way through and then
that's obviously when someone abided
detonated his suicide best
[Music]
can you tell us about the night who you
were going to the concert with and who
you were going to see
so i was going with my daughter eve she
was uh 14 at the time
uh and
the tickets had bought as a a surprise
at christmas
you know i'll say we spent
kind of the daddy and daughter time was
um kind of going to concerts and you
know just loved music and singing and
so yes it was just really the night was
just a celebration of that really
so we were um
we were in one of the very first boxes
up in the it's kind of like mid way up
uh in the arena so if if you were if i
was ariana grande singing on the stage
we were kind of like the first box here
um
when she came out
it was obviously mostly
girls but
like literally i had to cover my ears it
was that
like honestly it was
like deafening uh and yeah she she put
on a good show
it was a really good concert what
happened after the concert finished
where did you guys go
you know when we um
when we when we go out of the
um the box obviously we we
do a right into the city room
at 10 31 make our way through and then
that's obviously when someone abided
detonated his suicide best
broken
and can you remember the moment that
that happened when the bomb
detonated yeah yeah we're we're only six
meters away
i've only just found out initially we
were told we're 10 meters away
but i've found out um
like four or five weeks ago that we're
actually only six meters away i just
remember it i just felt winded
and i think i i obviously i didn't know
it were a bomb i initially i thought i'd
been shot or stabbed
and and i couldn't get my breath
um so i panicked
because i was like like [ __ ] like what's
going on like i couldn't breathe
um
and then i think i must have lost
consciousness then because the next
thing i know i'm kind of lying on the
floor
and and
basically like gargling on blood and
obviously i can i can see i'm losing a
lot of
blood um
and then obviously i see eve's not in a
good way
um and then that's kind of when i
probably know just from
kind of what's going on in the room that
it's obviously a bomb um
so yeah i've recently seen footage uh
one second before detonation
um
which yeah it's it's it's taken me a
while to get my head around it
to see that picture and then see the
picture afterwards where
basically everyone around us is dead and
and for some reason me and eve have
survived
um
so yeah it's it's it's taking a bit of a
yeah to get my head around that
a lot of the people that have uh died
were were were facing frontwards
so they they took the the shrapnel
you know basically all over the front of
them thankfully
we were
we'd walk past so
we we had our backs turned and
thankfully i was
in i was in front of eve so basically if
the shrapnel's coming in
in that trajectory i covered eve so i i
took
thankfully i i shielded eve uh from from
the blast
you know i knew i wasn't in a good way i
knew i was dying i knew i was losing a
lot of blood
um
and i just remember kind of saying to
myself you know
you you're not gonna make it
you know you you've got one job to do
now and that's to you know make sure eve
gets out and i knew
i knew that if i um if i closed my eyes
i'd be dead
just from the amount of blood that i was
losing obviously i didn't realize how
bad my injuries were
but i could tell from
you know the pool of blood that you know
i wasn't in a good way
and as a father what was it like to see
something like that happen to to your
daughter
no it's the worst worst thing on earth
um
because again i give myself a hard time
about it because
you know like most dads you know i
always said to eve like you never worry
when you're with me because i'll protect
you and keep you safe and nothing will
ever happen so i kind of
feel like i've let her down and
kind of failed as a dad and
um
yeah
my superhero caps got a bit of a rip in
it so yeah i always feel a bit guilty
about that
we were obviously shouting out for help
and
you know the
people were telling us that paramedics
were on the way and help was on the way
but it just felt like forever
um
and you know a lot of people have said
and
like my family have said like they were
always worried and upset for me because
they thought are in loads of pain and
scared and stuff but i wasn't i was like
really calm and
i wasn't in any pain
actually i was
like really like say i was just
literally just concentrating on even
just kind of
my breathing and just you know because i
knew like if i panicked i'd probably
lose more blood and it's like just to be
thinking of things like that when you're
dying it's just crazy really but kind of
an acceptance that
i probably wasn't going to make it and
i said to chris the security guard that
was was with me like tell my wife i love
her
suppose one second
[Music]
i've said this so many times
yeah that doesn't mean that it will get
easier today
i don't think people um
a lot of people understand like the
you know for your mind to go through
that and your body to go through that
you know to
kind of make peace with yourself
and almost like um
like an acceptance to the situation
and like to like to say like to people
you don't know like to tell your wife
you love her
you don't think you're gonna like see
anybody again
and they say it's a tough thing like
that like to accept that it's um
[Music]
it's a tough thing to go through and
that's why i'm like dead happy now to be
alive because like for an hour
i like to have to go through that and
just
like fight and
be alone and scared and
you know it was awful
we get taken out and and and that's when
i i i give up and yeah that's
that's that's the last i um
i kind of know about anything really
until probably a couple of weeks later
when i wake up in intensive care
i mean i was i was sat up in a awake and
talking a couple of days later but i i
don't remember that my first
recollection
um is probably a couple of weeks later
um
when when basically i'm i'm being told
by um
kind of my
consultant that
i've suffered a complete spinal cord
sever
and what injuries did you sustain
so i suffered 22 shrapnel wounds
from head to toe
it was one that hit me in the center of
the back
um completely severed my spinal cord at
t10 level which in layman's terms means
i'm paralyzed from the belly button down
i mean i had one that had gone through
my arm
smashed my ankle my tibia my fibia
but the
the second um
hit me on the side of the neck severed
two arteries
um and then yeah swallowed it ended up
in my stomach
was that a stroke of luck that that
happened
well yeah there's no
no explanation they're just it's just
they've said it it's a miracle where
just how close we were you know because
people died everyone around us died
pretty much instantly
um so yeah there's just no nobody can
explain it
they didn't really tell me about eve
they just they just kept saying that she
was alive because it was she was very
very much touch-and-go for
for quite a while just because the the
um
she had a very significant brain injury
basically one bolt got through and
basically went through her head
um
so she was
you know
she was in a good way for a long time so
[Music]
they didn't think she were gonna make it
um
so they just kept again i don't have any
recollection of it but apparently i you
know i was asking all the time and it
was just yeah she's alive um just got to
kind of concentrate on yourself now
which you you can't really say that to a
dad
um because that's that's what you live
for
as a family how have your lives changed
since that day
kind of the
the martin that you see in front of you
know is isn't the one that went to the
arena that night you know
that that martin died you know that that
night
um
and and kind of i suppose a new one was
born you know um so my life the life
that i knew in the life that i had kind
of ended that night
yeah so i think you know you you name it
you know
whether it's
you know having a shower going to the
toilet you know
how you drive
you know dressing yourself
you know how you get to places
where you stay it just affects it
affects every
way of life you know i think people look
at me and think you know
poor guy can't walk but actually you get
your head around that pretty quick it's
it's everything else that you
you know kind of stays hidden that you
you don't see you know
and and that that's the that's the
upsetting bit you know that that's the
bit that when i'm having a bad day
it'll get me down you know those are the
things that i don't think you ever get
your head around
do you ever get flashbacks to the event
oh yeah all the time
yeah
probably every night you know
it's just probably first thing and last
thing i think of every every day
everything that i'd gone through on the
night to to have woken up and be alive
and
and be in in one piece
so to speak um
even though i had two guys telling me i
wasn't going to walk again even though
you know i wasn't happy about it it was
kind of like well
i'm here and i'm alive so i'll take it
you know um i just remember thinking
like i'm
fishing authorities i'm not gonna be
able to take my dog for a walk and
i'm not gonna kick a ball again and you
know just like silly things really
but there was always a
you know a kind of a
an attitude of
well you know we crack on like you know
you've told me that like when does rehab
start when you know so i think they were
a bit kind of
balled over by it and i've since seen my
um
when i went to the spinal unit uh like
kind of the report that they did on me
and
they said like they've never seen like
an attitude like it you know just
they were worried about it at one place
they said like you know
i should have had a breakdown and
you know kind of a
total you know and i just never did you
know what i mean just
not gonna waste time doing that i'm here
and tell me what i'm gonna do and i'll
do it
and that's just why you know it's just
how i've been brought up
and how's your daughter eve today
she's doing all right you know um
the first time i went over to see you
one of the things i do remember is is
one of the consultants in manchester
saying
you know she's
you know there's probably not going to
be much there you know she probably
won't see she probably won't hear
she probably won't speak she won't be
able to move like they were saying that
she'd probably be in a vegetative start
um
but i don't think they'd ever met a
hibbert before um
we don't like being told what to do and
um
so yes or no like she you know she can
see she can hear
she speaks all the time which is great
um
i had a great video a few weeks back of
her
doing some walking unassisted
she's at school back at school now full
time she goes to a different school
um
she'll probably need care for the rest
of her life
um well i say you take it you know it's
um because there's 22 families i'd take
that tomorrow
i don't waste a day and yeah i'm just
i'm just dead happy to be here because
you know i shouldn't be here you know
what i mean i just think it's a crime
for me not to
to live life to the full and like to
help people and who are less fortunate
than me because
i think i've survived for a reason and i
think i know i've only just recently
really feel like i know what that is now
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna change the
world in my in my own way
[Music]
and i remember unlocking my phone and
what's up was on and i kind of closed
what's up and clicked on the camera
and the second i clicked the film
i saw what i guess
the whole world saw